die hawking strahlung aus schwarzen
löchern ist wohl der heilige gral der
physik wie funktioniert die genau wie
lässt sich nachweisen oder zumindest
experimentell beobachten
alle versuche in diese richtung scheinen
gnadenlos zum scheitern doch es gibt ein
modellsystem aus dem manch spannende
erkenntnisse rund um die hawking
strahlung ableiten kann und auch hawking
selbst hat seine eigene theorie dazu
konkretisiert wie genau dass er basiert
entwicklungszeit fixen herzlich
willkommen
die hawking strahlung wie zu beobachten
sind zu messen und nachzuweisen
das ist wohl der große traum eines jeden
physikers doch niemand schaffte es gibt
tatsächlich nur zwei dinge die wir ganz
sicher über die wissen stephen hawking
hat wie entdeckt und sie hat etwas mit
schwarzen löchern zu tun der hawking
strahlung auf die schliche gekommen
das würde tatsächlich die entdeckung
eines schwarzen loches bedeuten direkt
vor unserer nase liebe vorstellung ist
absolut wahnsinnig doch die sogenannte
hawking strahlung hat eine sehr geringe
intensität um wie derzeit mit teleskopen
auffangen zu können zudem befinden sich
kandidaten die als schwarze löcher in
frage käme in astronomischen distanzen
wobei zudem noch andere strahlungs
exakte den hoffen effekte überlagern
würden abschüssiger sie morgen selbst
hat vor mehr als 40 jahren über 44 die
these aufgestellt das war vielleicht gar
nicht wie alles fressenden
weltraummonster sind sondern das wohl
höchstwahrscheinlich kleine partikel in
form von hochenergetischer strahlung in
der lage sein der anziehungskraft des
schwarzen loches zu trotzen und den
ereignishorizont zu verlassen
die these am ereignishorizont entstehen
verschränkte teilchen paare und da wir
am ereignishorizont entstehen kann auch
eine gewisse anzahl im schwarzen loch
entweichen denn jenseits dieser eignet
ist es ja möglich
der ungeheure anziehungskraft des
schwarzen loches zu entfliehen kurz
gesagt sieben hawking hat bereiten
damals davon gesprochen dass schwarze
löcher wohl in der lage seien strahlung
auszusenden eine absolut bahnbrechende
these widerspricht einsteins allgemeiner
relativitätstheorie total und wie hat
dramatische konsequenzen und wie wurde
inzwischen per email nachgebaut
namen sind bis vor kurzem galten nämlich
alle infos rund um die hawking strahlung
als rein theoretische annahme erst 2014
ist es dann plötzlich die hawking
strahlung sei das erste mal
experimentell gemessen worden
die große frage die über allem steht
lautet wie soll sie funktionieren und
wie genau kommt die hawking strahlung
aus dem schwarzen loch heraus und wird
nicht wie alles andere hereingezogen
eine hoch spannende frage der
themenvorschlag für dieses video kommt
übrigens von marc-andre quickly
herzlichen dank dafür also 2014
veröffentlicht des steinauer vom
israelischen institute of technology in
haifa eine studie in der er tatsächlich
eine art hawking strahlung in seinem
fall aus schall nachweisen will er
behalf sich in seinem experiment mit
analogien und nutzte die tatsache dass
bestimmte systeme ähnlichen gesetzen der
schwerkraft folgend sieben jahre
bastelte er herum um hilfe eines bose
einstein kondensat im labor eine art
schwarzes loch verschaffen
doch sein herz noch lässt statt licht
oder materie keinen schall entweichen
eine art stilles loch also in seinem
modell system übernehmen die
schallwellen also die rolle jener
teilchen die bei einem schwarzen loch
die hawking strahlung ausmachen sollen
in seinem experiment bestrahlte er das
bose-einstein-kondensat mit laserlicht
so bilden sich fontane dichte pulse
sogenannte phononen auch als
schallwellen beschreibbar die
beschleunigen sich so in ihrem
begrenzten raum auf
überschallgeschwindigkeit die überschall
region ist also im übertragenen sinne
steinhauers schreibtisch ereignet von er
ließ seine apparatur mehr als sechs tage
lang laufen und tatsächlich nach mehr
als 4.500 wiederholung konnte er auf der
einen seite und auf der anderen seite
jeweils einen strohmann partikel
beobachten das entscheidende dabei
steinhauer erkannte korrelation zwischen
den punkten auf beiden seiten bevorzuge
eine sensation denn die plastic schluss
zu dass sich im kondensat paare von
miteinander verschränkten photonen
gebildet hatten
dieses experiment würde tatsächlich die
kanten natur der hawking strahlung
schützen im scheinbar leeren raum bilden
sich paare von teilchen und ihren
antiteilchen jeweils eines davon würde
dann mitgerissen das andere quasi
entkommen und würde somit die hawking
strahlung bilden zum ersten mal
überhaupt will der israelische
wissenschaftler mit gezeigt haben dass
ein schwarzes loch eben doch auch
partikel erwischen lässt und nicht wie
von vielen gedacht alles aber auch
wirklich alles in sich aufsaugt doch das
laborexperiment von steinhauser wird in
der wissenschaftlichen fachwelt heftig
diskutiert und wieder sind sich einig
dass dies keineswegs den
heiligengrabe physik antasten es sei
schließlich nicht sicher ob es sich bei
der flüssigkeit tatsächlich um ein
bose-einstein-kondensat handel
steinhauses laborexperiment liefere
zudem keinesfalls den beweis das
astrophysikalische löcher tatsächlich
hawking strahlung aussenden lediglich
könne man die ergebnisse als neues
wissen über kalte atome deuten wenn
überhaupt unter klar steinhauser hat
natürlich kein richtiges schwarzes loch
analysiert und nicht wirklich den beweis
für die funktionsweise der hawking
strahlung geliefert in seinem aktuellen
ist ihm dennoch etwas gelungen was einem
an einem relativistischen schwarzen war
unmöglich ist die vorgänge außerhalb und
innerhalb des akkus zwischen loches zu
vergleichen und er ist sich sicher damit
hawking berechnung selbst bestätigt zu
haben jetzt noch einmal auf die frage
von marc-andré wieder zurückzukommen dem
jetzigen wissensstand zur folge ist ein
schwarzes loch durch seine existenz und
seine funktionsweise für entstehen und
das aussenden der hawking strahlung
verantwortlich beide bedingen einander
quasi sind miteinander durch
verschiedenste vorgänger
aneinandergekoppelt für den steckbrief
der schwarzen löcher bedeutet diese
erkenntnis zur hawking strahlung sie
sind nicht schwarz können stattdessen
sogar an masse verlieren und grob gesagt
auch verdampfen
die alles entscheidende frage an dieser
stelle müssten dann nicht alle infos
verloren gehen die das schwarze loch je
gesammelt hat stephen hawking hat 2016
selbst eine antwort darauf gegeben black
holes and the nottie vermittelt also
übersetzt in etwa schwarze löcher sind
nicht so schwarz wie bisher immer
gemacht wurden und sie sind auch keine
gefängnisse hawking schreibt zusammen
mit zwei kollegen in seinem paper von
fernen westen das alles was in ein
schwarzes loch gerät ihren
ereignishorizont verändert die
informationen hinterlassen quasi einen
fingerabdruck auf der grenzfläche des
schwarzen loches und verändern damit
auch die aus dem loch entweichende
strahlung im umkehrschluss könnte die
entweichende strahlung also verraten
welche teilchen genau wie
veränderungen bewirkt hat ihr seht also
die forschung rund um die hawking
strahlung ist und bleibt spannend und es
gibt weiterhin noch so viele fragen zu
klären
der heilige gral der für sich war wird
weiterhin auf brillante köpfe die in der
lage sind seine rettet für immer zu
lösen wenn es also dazu neues gibt dann
erfahrt ihr es natürlich hier
wenn er nichts zu verpassen wollen also
kein video sollte hier ein abo aufs auge
und vergesst nicht den auf die glocke
hier geht es weiter mit sieben hawking
sagt weltuntergang voraus das ist ein
ziemlich pessimistisch hawking dem bada
kennenlernen wenn es euch interessiert
drauf klicken und schon geht es los und
ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran